et notre invité ce matin c'est
Jean-François colosimont bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être là historien essayiste
auteur de ce livre la crucifixion de
l'Ukraine Milan de guerre de religion en
Europe c'est aux éditions Albin Michel
on va bien sûr parler de cette guerre
avec vous puisque ça fait 9 mois
quasiment jour pour jour maintenant que
la Russie a envahi l'Ukraine est-ce que
vous êtes surpris par la tournure que
prend cette guerre 9 mois après pour
dire la vérité d'abord nous sommes nous
avons tous été surpris plus ou moins par
l'agression de l’ailleurs Poutine contre
l'Ukraine puisque elle semblait tout à
fait démesurée et surtout à la paraisser
à terme forcément perdante parce que la
grande loi de toutes les guerres du 20e
siècle c'est que une armée d'occupation
qui à la fin ne sait plus ce qu'elle
fait là loin de chez elle finit toujours
par être battu par un peuple qui résiste
à perdre cette guerre quoi qu'il arrive
déjà
on l'a perdu regardez si vous voulez
bien regarder je veux dire regardez les
buts de guerre de la lumière Poutine
n'est-ce pas aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on
voit l'Ukraine existe de manière
solidaire unique comme une nation forte
ce qu'elle n'était pas forcément avant
la guerre
vous le dire et c'est comme un président
un peu Fallot un acteur devenu un homme
politique par hasard et aujourd'hui il
apparaît comme Churchill l'OTAN on
disait que l'OTAN était en coma dépassé
l'OTAN recrute un pays comme la Finlande
alors que on la finalisation c'était le
synonyme effectivement de la neutralité
maximale à l'égard de Moscou les
Américains sont de retour en Europe
alors qu'ils avaient un grand
rendez-vous dans le Pacifique et on voit
qu'il déploie en fait une espèce de
nouveau plan Marshall n'est-ce pas et
puis l'Allemagne réarme c'est pas une
petite nouvelle le tabou l'interdit de
1945 élevé donc quand on voit que
finalement la guerre Poutine a abouti
exactement à l'inverse de tout ce qu'il
recherchait puisque l'Ukraine lui tourne
le dos définitivement veut s'arrimer à
l'Europe et que l'Europe s'engage aussi
même si c'est de manière très indirecte
par la livraison d'armes mais l'Europe
où il y avait là encore un interdit
n'est-ce pas l'Europe s'affranchit
complètement je dirais que puisqu'on a
beaucoup de complotistes en France il en
reste assez là-dessus la bonne question
à leur poser c'est ne penserez ne
pense-t-il pas que au fond le lien
Poutine pour être un agent de la CIA
parce que le résultat est tellement
inverse à tout ce que Poutine a projeté
et à ce que c'est complotistes pouvaient
penser que l'on voit que Poutine adore
est déjà perdu maintenant cette perte
elle peut s'étirer dans le temps causer
un nombre de morts de souffrance dont on
sait que lui il n'en a qu'une je veux
dire et par rapport aux Ukrainiens qu'il
est en train d'affamer et par rapport
aux Russes qu'il est en train d'envoyer
à une mort
certainement son pays selon vous il a
fait plus que l'affaiblir et il l'a
plongé dans un isolement complet
puisqu'il n'y a il n'y a pas de
véritable soutien international il y a
le club des méchants la Chine l'Iran
la Turquie l'Inde aussi l'un de Monsieur
maudit ce n'est pas un pays formidable
du point de vue des libertés loin sans
faut donc ce club des puissances
émergentes en fait le soutien du bout
des doigts ce que par exemple six inping
leaders chinois souhaite c'est que la
Russie soit affaibli mais pas trop pour
qu'elle reste une nuisance face à ce que
tout ce club nomme de manière très vague
l'Occident comment vous l'expliquez ce
choix cette stratégie devl Vladimir
Poutine est-ce qu'il était mal renseigné
ou est-ce qu'il s'est vu trop puissant
les deux vous avez parfaitement raison
il y a surtout aussi je crois cette
incapacité vous voyez on se dit est-ce
qu'il est fou bon la vérité c'est que
comme le dit Chester Stone un fou c'est
celui qui a tout perdu sauf la raison
donc il est dans une forme de
rationalité par rapport à lui-même
n'est-ce pas simplement il bute un
véritable point de déréalisation c'est à
dire qu'il a perdu pied avec la réalité
et pourquoi tout simplement parce que il
se voit être opposé une résistance
farouche par une entité dont il dit
qu'il n'existe pas pour lui l'Ukraine
n'existe pas mais voilà que l'Ukraine
est en train de devenir son tombeau et
là et c'est là où nous avons un risque
maximal c'est qu'en fait il est en train
véritablement de chavirer tout en
restant extrêmement rationnel dans sa
démarche de malheureusement pour les
ukrainiens et pour nous tous et
l'Ukraine est en train de devenir son
tombeau à lui c'est à dire que lui ne
résistera pas à l'issue de cette guerre
en Ukraine il devra partir pour vous oui
mais nous soyons pas dupe de la
personnalisation du pouvoir qui est en
place au Kremlin n'est-ce pas bien sûr
que c'est lui le chef c'est lui le boss
bien sûr que c'est lui l'arbitre mais il
y a tout un système autour de lui dont
finalement il
incarne ce système il porte ce système
mais ce système pourrait tout à fait lui
survivre et ce système c'est quoi c'est
qu'il a fondé la première
espiacre espion le pouvoir des espions
au monde même soulignons soviétique vous
aviez d'un côté le polype bureau et de
l'autre le KGB après 1991 le KGB petit à
petit a pris tous les pouvoirs
tous étatique économique culturel et
même religieux puisqu'il a son pontife
n'est-ce pas en la personne du
patriarche Kyril de Moscou et de toutes
les Russie qui bénissent cette guerre
comme une croisade comme une guerre
sainte or ce qui rime
depuis toujours c'est un agent des
services donc les services ont tout pris
ces services hier sous l'Union
soviétique ils étaient ordonnés à une
forme d'idéale communiste plus ou moins
aujourd'hui leur solidaire c'est la
survie le problème que nous avons c'est
que c'est là où le point de gravité le
plus extrême c'est que Vladimir Poutine
il ne cherche pas à imposer la puissance
de la Russie désormais il cherche à
sauver son régime un régime mafieux un
régime oligarchique un régime cleptomane
et un régime criminel on le voit en
Ukraine on pouvait le voir un peu plus
tôt en Russie rappelez-vous l'affaire
Navalny qu'est-ce qu'on sait justement
de son entourage de l'entourage de
Vladimir Poutine il y a des débats il y
a des débats parce que encore une fois
comme c'est une oligarchiste un clan
c'est une famille au sens des familles
de New York
mafieuse il y a par exemple un homme
assez important pas trop cher qui est le
compagnon de route de Poutine dans son
ascension au pouvoir un peu plus âgée
que lui comme lui sortit du KGB et du
FSB et dont le fils est ministre
d'économie
d'agriculture parmi et pourrait un jour
devenir le masque du système si
véritablement le règlement de la guerre
imposé le départ de Poutine de notre
côté vous avez de véritables criminels
par exemple cadirof le chef de la
tchénie n'est-ce pas
donc ces gens là eux vous les voyez ce
sont des pouces
à la guerre à la gare absolu total parce
que eux dans leur situation de
criminalité radicale ils doivent eux
aussi absolument survivre
et donc ils sont prêts à jouer leur
atout sur cette guerre et survivre ça
passe par la poursuite de la guérilla
que des vate en guerre dans l'entourage
proche de Vladimir poutinho personne qui
pousse à la paix disons que moi c'est
pas mon rôle mais si j'avais un
conseiller ceux qui
ne sont pas véritablement va-t-en guerre
je leur conseillerais quand même de
faire profil bas parce qu'on voit aussi
que le système procède par élimination
et aujourd'hui hyper concentré vous vous
souvenez de toutes ces morts
mystérieuses d'oligarques qui se sont
suicidés après avoir tué leur famille
enfin on est véritablement dans des
abîmes de véritablement de terreur aussi
donc ce système qui est un système
terroriste et bien je veux dire qui va
le critiquer voilà ensuite il y a des
tensions énormes
la milice Wagner et les tchétchène sont
par exemple en buts aux militaires et
réclame la tête des militaires et
obtiennent
des militaires donc effectivement c'est
un système dans lequel c'est introduit
un flottement parce que ce système
encore une fois est en train de perdre
ça veut dire que si Vladimir Poutine
quitte le pouvoir qui va lui succéder
est-ce que ce sera il y a un risque en
cas de révolution de palais d'avoir
quelqu'un une personne n'a encore plus
radicale encore plus vate en guerre
c'est un peu je dirais un des mirages
que nous aimons entretenir nous avec une
idée un peu unilatérale du progrès que
après un méchant il y aura un doux il
peut y avoir pire qu'un méchant
oui non pas que venir Poutine soit un
exemple d'humanité loin sans faut mais
au moins il est rompu depuis une
vingtaine d'années aux usages
internationaux on peut voir apparaître
un véritable simplement chef de guerre
tribord militaire
tribunaux milicien encore plus je dirais
avec une idéologie encore plus maximale
qu'est-ce que est-ce que vous nous avez
dit vous ne pensez que que Vladimir
Poutine n'est pas fou qu'il y a quand
même une part de rationalité même si
c'est la sienne est-ce que il y a une
part de paranoïa aussi chez Vladimir
Poutine est-ce que il a peur de se faire
assassiner est-ce que ça explique aussi
certaines de ses décisions
peur de se faire assassiner il a peur je
crois il est dans ce complexe des tyran
qui cherche en fait à s'immortaliser
voyez on le décrit comme malade alors un
jour on dit cancer du pancréas mais
enfin c'est un seul Pacha il serait plus
là un cancer de la prostate un cancer
voilà une Parkinson terminale combien
a-t-il de sosies c'est pas toutes ces
questions un peu je dirais qui
participent non la réalité toute simple
c'est quoi voyez son visage il est
botoxé il est botoxé là la revanche
l'information est assez sûr il blessait
de trouver des tas de cure de jouvence
il cherche véritablement s'immortaliser
à s'éterniser et on sait qu'il souffre
d'un véritable complexe hypocondriaque
de crainte de tout ce qui est microbes
moustiques enfin etc et donc il vit en
fait d'ores et déjà dans un bunker ce
qui n'est pas une nouvelle rassurante
personnalité sa psychologie explique la
conduite de cette guerre puisque sa
psychologie c'est un problème c'est un
mannequin c'est un manichéen alors le
magnétisme c'est une vieille religion
n'est-ce pas c'est l'opposition radicale
du bien et du mal je suis le bien vous
êtes l'autre vous êtes le mal l'histoire
réclame que je vous anéanti c'est de
préférence dans une apocalypse qui verra
en fin le la lumière triomphé bon ça
cette structure mentale c'est quand même
été celle du marxisme vous voyez avec la
lutte des classes ce qui explique on
pouvait envoyer des millions de gens au
goulag pour les supprimer c'était
dégénéré irrécupérables ça c'est sa
matrice mentale et c'est un ni liste
c'est à dire qu'il est véritablement
dans l'apologie de la force brute et on
le voit bien en Ukraine ou il enchaîne
par exemple des opérations qui sont
effectivement aux opérations qui visent
à ramener l'Ukraine à l'âge de pierre à
soumettre jésus-chrenien en fait au
régime de la fin et du froid tout
l'hiver mais tout ça ça revient aussi
une dimension de punition puisqu'ils
osent exister et ils osent résister donc
il faut qu'il soit sévèrement
sanctionner anéanti il y a une espèce de
religion du néant derrière tout ça ça
c'est un nouveau pas pour vous cette
stratégie et de viser les industries de
viser de privés les Ukrainiens d'eau
d'électricité alors que vous le dites
l'hiver est là et qu'il y a des
températures de moins 10 c'est un
nouveau pack
son calcul va être démenti puisque il
cherche à démoraliser en fait quoi le
peuple l'arrière n'est-ce pas pour
gagner sur le front où il perd
militairement ou en tout cas il est en
difficulté n'est-ce pas alors sur le
front et en difficulté donc on va
frapper l'arrière pour que l'arrière
dise au soldat ukrainien qui sont sur le
front stop mais il se trompe
complètement parce que il n'y a
malheureusement pas de plus grande
matrice pour former une nation ou pour
galvaniser une nation pour unir une
nation malheureusement il y a pas le
meilleur matrice qu'une agression qu'une
guerre qu'une invasion
toutes les différences entre tous les
Ukrainiens elles sont nombreuses ces
différences de culte de culture de
sensibilité de langue même un peu en
quelque sorte tout ça tout ça tout ça
c'est fini il n'est plus question pour
les Ukrainiens les Ukrainiens sont tous
derrière en fait quoi l'idée que il leur
faut anéantir à leur tour Poutine il
faut débarrasser le monde de Poutine et
là ils n'ont pas tort et là où nous
sommes avec eux
ces derniers jours Emmanuel Macron a
parlé de crimes de guerre dit qu'elle ne
pouvait pas rester un puni est-ce que
vous croyez au fait qu'un jour Vladimir
Poutine devra répondre de ce qui est
qualifié de crime de guerre et s'il
comparaîtra un jour pour vous autant
qu'il survivent pour autant que il ne
soit pas effectivement remplacé par ses
amis
à travers l'usage d'un poison ou etc
tout ce système devrait être jugé et ce
jugement nous permettra enfin de
d'exorciser le spectre du communisme
dont Poutine et l'héritier il a
lobotomisé les Russes il a entretenu des
Russes dans l'amnésie des crimes du
communisme souvenez-vous il a fermé
mémorial la grande association qui
luttait pour collecter aux collationner
les archives du Goulag il l'a fermé
quelques jours avant
l'invasion de l'Ukraine parce qu'il
fallait que on gomme les crimes du passé
qu'on en parle plus afin de pouvoir
commettre les crimes du présent c'est ça
vraiment une décision extrêmement fort
symboliquement
et donc on le juge en jugera ce régime
dont il est encore une fois en quelque
sorte l'épiphanie
une place importante dans la première
Kremlin bien sûr puisque en fait le
parti bolche a voulu éradiquer l'église
y est presque arrivé jusqu'à ce que
Staline ait besoin de l'église pour
résister à Hitler ensuite c'est avec un
cas l'Église a cherché à survivre à
travers un pacte avec l'État dans après
1991 elle n'avait plus besoin mais comme
l'église était infiltrée par les
services les hommes des services dont le
patriarche qui rime n'est-ce pas on
renoué une espèce d'union sacrée c'est
l'alliance aujourd'hui de l'encensoir et
du missile et vous voyez bien que tout
le langage de Poutine et tout le langage
de Kyril c'est le même langage que celui
d'Oussama Ben Laden on promet au soldats
qui seront des martyrs absents de leur
péchés qu'ils iront au Paradis on est
véritablement là on voit que le problème
que nous avons cette haine de l'Occident
vont pas que l'Occident ce soit la
perfection mais la différence de
l'Europe c'est que l'Europe elle a
peut-être commis beaucoup de crimes elle
a aussi engendrer
tout en fait les antidotes à ces crimes
vous voyez nous avons été peut-être une
puissance coloniale mais c'est en Europe
qu'on a pensé l'aNTIC colonialisme aussi
donc c'est cette haine qui là c'est
cette haine de la capacité critique de
retour sur soi parce que très
précisément lui encore une fois il a
amputé les Russes de la mémoire du
communisme pour asseoir son sa propre
tyrannie sa propre autocratie auprès des
Russes est-ce qu'il est vraiment le
soutien de la population russe d'abord
les Russes sont intoxiquées n'est-ce pas
je vous dis enfin les Russes ceux qui
sont encore en Russie puisque on connaît
aujourd'hui une vague d'immigrations
russes qui est certainement
supérieur à celle de 1917
on compte officiellement un million 8 à
2 millions de Russes qui sont déjà
partis peut-être en fait 3 millions
peut-être 3 millions et demi ce sont les
forces vives de ce pays ce sont les
intellectuels les artistes les
journalistes les activités
tous ceux qui n'a pas eu le temps de
mettre en prison parce que les autres
sont en prison bon reste une population
sortie du communisme le lomo soviétique
us ne l'homme rouge dont parlait
avec ses 8 et eux c'est très simple ils
sont soumis à une propagande terrible
ils n'ont plus accès à aucun moyen
d'information critique et à la
télévision russe on leur montre les
bombardements sûrs en leur disant vous
voyez ce que c'est la ski fait à ces
gens et on leur dit mais l'OTAN est là
et l'OTAN veut exterminer donc là encore
on a un processus de terreur un
processus de peur n'est-ce pas un
processus d'endoctrinement sur la sortie
de la gare est-ce que selon vous la
Russie peut entrer dans une phase de
négociation est-ce que Poutine négocier
ces derniers temps c'est lui qui vous
les négocier à son avantage parce qu'il
connaissait des revers militaires il y a
six mois c'était les Ukrainiens qui
étaient prêts à négocier le problème
qu'on a c'est qu'on ne voit pas
aujourd'hui eu égard en position
respective des uns et des autres et le
président Macron a parfaitement raison
là-dessus les Ukrainiens c'était à eux
de dire la paix qu'ils veulent parce
qu'ils l'ont gagner par le sang verser
donc et enfin on a une dictature tout
simplement n'est-ce pas qui nous fera
perdre aucun de ses acquis parce que si
elle accepte de renoncer cette dictature
à ses acquis elle dévisse
elle perd là elle perd même sa capacité
de représenter la Russie alors une
solution ça serait certainement d'en
arriver parce que cette guerre elle est
pas mondiale mais elle est mondialisée à
travers les céréales à travers les
énergies fossiles à travers les
interventions des différentes
puissances émergentes enfin etc donc
dans cette guerre mondialisée l'idéal
évidemment serait que finalement les
territoires envahis et pris par la
lumière Poutine soit administré par les
Nations unies par une force
d'interposition le temps raisonnable de
faire des référendums que à l'heure
qu'il est l'Ukraine gagnerait oui mais
justement est-ce que vous pensez que
Vladimir Poutine il peut accepter ses
conditions qu'est-ce qui peut lâcher
dans ses territoires annexés dans le
long base dans la Crimée théoriquement
le seul territoire qui ne peut qui ne
voudra pas lâcher c'est la Crimée parce
que la Crimée c'est en fait la clé c'est
le sas
par lequel la Russie peut accéder au
reste du monde sinon la Russie doit
passer par le Pôle Nord pour aller dans
n'importe quelle mer n'est-ce pas ça
c'est une longue
obsessions je pense qu'il peut y avoir
des négociations parce que ça gronde des
convenu ça a été que ces populations
russophone et orthodoxes sur lesquelles
il comptait sa fameuse opération
spéciale débarquées acquiesf remplacées
avoir un régime à sa botte tout ça n'a
rien à marcher parce que ces populations
depuis 2014 elles vivent avec les agents
secrets et avec les miliciens de Poutine
elles ont ces populations étaient
soumises à tellement d'exactions
qu'elles ne veulent pas de Vladimir
Poutine et qu'elle préfère adhérer aux
rêves de Kiev d'entrer dans l'Europe
donc en fait il a encore il a perdu
voyez c'est ses alliés supposés se
retombent contre lui
maintenant vous voyez bien aussi que
tous les plans se jouent en même temps
ils déportent ces populations c'est un
crime de guerre il déporte ses
populations civiles il les jette en
Russie il des peuples ces territoires
parce que précisément y compris dans cet
territoire les Ukrainiens résistent à
son emprise sur une dernière question
sur la suite le 13 décembre il y aura à
Paris une conférence pour le crâne pour
la reconstruction de l'Ukraine à
l'initiative d'Emmanuel Macron et de
volodières ça peut froisser Vladimir
Poutine
qui a tendu la perche à la lumière
Poutine pour qu'il sorte de cette guerre
c'est quand même le président de la
République française n'est-ce pas
maintenant maintenant le président est
aussi dans son exercice lorsqu'il
convoque une conférence internationale
et lorsque nous montrons notre soutien à
l'Ukraine pourquoi parce que la bataille
que mène l'Ukraine c'est pas la bataille
des Ukrainiens c'est une bataille des
Européens merci beaucoup Jean-François
colasi merci d'avoir été notre invité je
rappelle évidemment votre livre la
crucifixion de l'Ukraine mi-long de
guerre de religion en Europe et c'est
aux éditions Albin Michel merci d'être
venu nous voir on passe au club des
territoires